no problem good morning constantine
uh good morning good morning steve
so it's nice it's nice to see you oh not
a all not at all uh very interesting to
me that i had uh communication from your
wife who said constantine's 30th
birthday
you have been following me on youtube
you use link in your classroom and you
would like to she figured it would be a
nice uh thing for you to have a
conversation with me i'm only too glad
to oblige
so and i'm very curious so you are a
teacher of english
or
i guess so right now yeah okay uh go
ahead well i guess i've been teaching
english for five years so far and uh
i've been using link for two years in a
row
and i i've been using that for myself so
i took my english through
a completely different level to a more
advanced one
using your approach
and
on the other hand i applied your methods
to my own teaching experience my own
teaching approach so
each and every student of mine they go
through a link
so it's just compulsory
if they want to if they want to study
with me they have to do link
that just doesn't it doesn't work
otherwise you know now how does what is
your school uh i mean very often in
schools they have their curriculum and
they have the regulations
and and we find example they'll say well
you know if they get on link they might
encounter through the internet some
undesirable people
and there's no accreditation all those
kinds of restrictions that uh school
administrators put in front of teachers
who want to use link
uh for sure
because i don't belong to any particular
school it's just i'm sorry just
an iphone
because i don't belong to any particular
school i'm just a private english tutor
so i set my own rules and there are no
restrictions hey
actually i hate restrictions in schools
so
i really admire your approach
and um well you know
there was certainly one thing i would
like to tell you that i really uh admire
you as a person and i just want you to
know that you have changed my life in a
certain way because you have inspired
not only me but so many people
to learn new languages to actually to
challenge it because before meeting link
oh is it time there all right so uh
before actually uh coming across link i
always
had this dream and had this vision that
i would like to speak spanish and many
other numerous languages but uh there
was always some
obstacles like grammar it was so
complicated and it i was thought that
it's gonna it would take me years you
know just to learn five languages or so
and uh the incredible thing about link
is that you really give these tools that
um make everything easier and you just
understand everything is so clear
everything becomes simple you just
follow the rules and you follow the
steps
and it gets you there right
so i really i appreciate you for that
and uh probably this is the most
important thing i would like to say
i appreciate it
the problem is not everyone understands
link a lot of people are conditioned by
the school systems or where's lesson one
where's chapter one sure uh
i want to speak they think they're gonna
speak speak speak but they don't have
any words so yeah there are lots of uh
lots of problems so in effect right now
we're trying to simplify it and in a way
make it give people more immediate
gratification like the sense of
achievement earlier because i think you
and me we're perhaps more committed like
we understand that in the long run what
matters is not what we should say after
week one but what we can say after six
months or after year right it's each
time it takes time for sure yeah for
sure uh the thing is that maybe it's
going to be useful for you um well
throughout these two years i've been
teaching maybe uh i don't know
dozens of students
and what agreement i may ask what age
group it depends it can be starting from
16 up to 50
right different wide range of people and
i would say that
it's really hard for people to
understand to get the point how to use
it
and
i can also tell you that
well mostly it refers to people who have
some kind of creative jobs like
designers and so on and mostly women to
be honest okay so they say
that they
really they like things they would
always go for duolingo or whatever
just because of design design of the
website so this they're actually they
don't like the design and that becomes
an obstacle that prevents them from
learning language which is kind of
ridiculous for me but for them this is
important so maybe uh you know they they
basically what they say is that if the
the website has
i know more attractive design that they
would definitely go for it so maybe that
that might be a tip for for link
i think that's very good advice what
we're doing in the sort of web that the
link 4.0 that we're now slowly building
out the design is we feel more
attractive
and
and also we simplify it a lot for the
beginners so that they have less choice
because a lot of times people come in
and there's too much choice and they're
bewildered um
we there are a number of things i won't
go into detail but
and we're only starting to roll it out
but it very much addresses the point
that you've made we also think for
example our library is hopeless it's
very difficult to find things in there
and so yeah we're we've come up with a
very good system we feel of how you
follow people and you get a feed of
stuff that people you're following are
studying eventually you'll be able to
connect your favorite you know sources
of
content on the internet so we i agree
with you and a number of people have
made these comments one of the things
that bothers me the most is that people
say i love link but i can't get my
friends to use link
uh okay
wow
so anyway those are we do appreciate i
mean the system the basic
idea that you have to listen and read a
lot and that we make it easier to
accumulate vocabulary through listening
and reading that's the fundamental thing
you can contact people and speak to them
and i have spoken to we have our members
that i've spoken to in russian in
ukrainian and romania and stuff like
that i can do that when i reach a
certain level but until i'm at that
level
i don't like
looking at someone through skype that i
don't understand what they're saying and
they can yeah
same for me sure no doubt so which
languages are you working on at length
you personally
uh personally at the moment i'm working
on chinese so uh last last seven months
i spent in china and uh i spent it
mostly in guangdong province so
guangzhou yes and then lived in shanghai
just a little bit in hong kong
and um
and you know i was
i was actually making this kind of
experiment for myself because i just
decided for myself that i'm going to
focus mostly in six months on reading
and listening only right without
speaking and so on of course you have to
speak once you get some kind of chinese
cafe just to order some food
i mean you have no choice right but
apart from that mostly i didn't speak
and now i came to the point when i feel
like speaking so i've accumulated some
number of words and number of patterns
as i call them
and now i would like just to express
them so i found myself a person i'm
going to speak with starting september
and i'm looking forward for that really
um and
just like you said i remember your video
about your traveling around asia yes
and you said that you you you bought
some kind of vocabulary like pocket
dictionary for uh vietnamese or burmese
or whatever and you couldn't say word
you didn't express yourself right
because it's useless uh yeah and
understand that point once if you don't
spend your time just reading and
listening a lot that you just
it's really hard well for me personally
and it was surprising how difficult it
is to remember even a few phrases like
in vietnamese after a week there i could
still only say three things you know
it's it's very difficult you need a lot
you need a lot
and
yeah
and the other thing too is i think
language learning and language related
activities need to be meaningful so i
always find that the my language partner
whoever i eventually choose to speak to
in whatever language i'm learning
we have to have things in common we
actually have to have meaningful things
you
to
talk
have some silly person there who has no
interest in you and you have no interest
in them
exactly yeah uh exactly so uh
maybe you will be interested in that i'm
gonna tell you a little bit about my
let's call it a project right so um as i
said before like i've been introducing a
lot of people to link and to your
approach to language learning and some
people can afford the lessons with me
some people just you know they're a
little bit lazy and they would like to
know more about language learning
because what seems obvious for me it's
not always obvious for them right
so
i did it again and again so i tried to
explain link again and again then i had
to record like a tutorial
in order not to waste time every time
people ask me to do that because so many
people asked me to do that actually
and then i came up with an idea
of combining your approach i mean
explaining how to use link in a way uh
with my own teaching practice and with
something that i actually took from luca
luca lampariello yes so he has some kind
of language course i don't know what
exactly in that course except for the
things that uh just short videos that i
could see on youtube
but i'm i'm working on some kind of
let's say a video workshop
consisting of
numerous videos explaining a few things
uh including how to use link from my
perspective
and how to use other sources like italki
and other things and also how to how to
build that relationship between the
teacher and the student because
uh what i really
admire in your approach is that
um you know you should understand that
you probably you are familiar with the
russian or ukrainian mentality let's
call it the soviet
mentality students in schools and soviet
union
are very passive in their thinking
that's not unique to them by the way
most students are passive okay
so that's the that's the thing and uh
when i have classes with my students
usually they're just waiting for
something for me all the time and where
they they don't understand something
they just keep silent and then i go and
i ask them like why do you keep silent i
mean if you don't know the word ask me
uh keep asking questions be active right
and for example every class that i have
with my students uh
i usually they they should have some
kind of topic in their mind to discuss
that they would like to discuss right so
you know sometimes you just um start the
conversation and people like okay what
do you want to speak about and uh
they're like i don't know maybe you will
choose the topic so it doesn't work for
me so um if you
if you're interested i would like to
discuss the
let's say um
the steps that you take in link
how to your work how you work with it
because uh to my surprise i guess maybe
um half a year ago i discovered for
myself even though i've been using the
program for two years
um
i use it in a slightly different way
that you do right
but nevertheless i i discovered for
myself that it works so i'm gonna
describe it shortly and if you tell me
what you think about it right
so it's gonna be a new way um so of
course a person chooses the topic choose
the text which is compelling to to him
or her
and then start reading so i usually
describe it like that they start reading
on monday and this is completely new
text right uh they they read it once uh
they might listen to it once and then
they upload the audio to their
gadget iphone whatever smartphone and
then they start listening at least an
hour and a half a day
and then next day they come back to the
same text
they come back to the same text they
read it out loud
they do the flash cards which is
compulsory
i make them do that
and
then i ask them to do the shadowing
always
and then they close their laptops
computer whatever and they just go out
and listen passively an hour and a half
a day
so the thing is that they spent
like that
from five to seven days listening to the
same own text right
so as far as i'm concerned you keep on
reading different texts not stumbling up
on one text
but um
i did it in a different way so i just i
asked my students to focus on one text
for uh several days until they get i
don't know 80 percent of vocabulary
right or understanding uh
i think it's different i can see that
it's different from your way but i can
tell you that it works i mean for my
students for two years i can prove it
easily i i would believe that it works
okay yeah i understand that i'm a
dilettante when it comes to language
learning
come on no i mean i i'm not learning for
any test
these people who are studying with you
they are learning that perhaps they need
it for their work or their
career or so there's a little more
pressure
so for me my approach typically is i
have to go through
some
usually quite boring beginner content is
somewhat inevitable that at the
beginning
and i do listen to that many many times
because it's so difficult to understand
anything even if you've read it and
you've looked up all the words and you
hear it you still don't understand it so
i stay with those texts quite a lot but
as soon as i can get to authentic
content
okay then i'm just i just want to listen
to things that are interesting to me
so you know every day for example when i
was on uh on ukrainian i would download
podcast from chromats gerardo even if i
already understood 50 60 it didn't
matter every day was something new it
was a new interview they were talking
about different things
and so that was interesting to me
and now i'm doing polish and it's the
same way i want to move into things that
are of interest to me but if i wanted to
try and really nail down the language
like
get better at it get better at speaking
at it i would do more along the lines of
what you were doing there's no question
right if you can stay with it because
a lot of the structures of the language
are going to be present in each text so
if you really become familiar with the
structures in that one text and because
each time you listen there's so many
things that are familiar to you then
you're sort of reinforcing the only
concern is
that like i i can't remember who it was
all right this book i went i mentioned
in one of my videos by manfred spitzer
about learning of the brain and he says
the brain requires two things it
requires repetition
and it requires novelty
so oh yeah there is a point and there's
other people who have written about this
too there is a point where if you stay
with the same material too long
you're learning less and less
for sure so you have to strike a balance
between repetition and novelty that's
the only thing but as long as i think
when the language when we have trouble
understanding the language the challenge
of understanding it in a sense
represents that novelty we're still
trying to understand it okay so but when
we reach a certain level then going over
the same text again and again becomes
just boring boring so there's no longer
novelty there's no alignment
there so that's that's the only thing
but otherwise and i mean i personally
don't do shadowing but a lot of people
do
and uh and it does get people talking
like if people you know as a teacher
people want to see results like i can
see something so there's more yeah so
there's more of an uh you know a need
for you to demonstrate that they're
starting to speak so and i think
shadowing definitely works and lucas i
think luke has a phenomenal uh polyglot
too so
to me that sounds good i mean any people
can use these things in different ways
for different purposes and so forth sure
yeah yeah absolutely and and if there's
any way we can work with you in in in
your area we're happy to cooperate with
with in different ways to to help what
you're doing and yeah we're very
interested i don't know how many users
we have in harkin but you might be a big
part of our market in arkham i don't
know
well actually i uh i don't live here i
just arrived here today
i'm kind of it's kind of complicated i
was born in saint petersburg in 1991 i
was uh my family moved to crimea which
you know is notoriously famous now yes
being
you know this weird state yes so and
last year's i spent in kiev and i was
there when my done happened so i'm
familiar with the situation and there
are many things that
um and last uh last six months i spent
in china like i told you right
yeah and uh so it's it's like that so
i'm mostly i'm connected definitely i'm
connected to russian-speaking world and
ukrainian-speaking world yeah yeah for
sure
i must tell you that for me the whole my
just off the subject here but my
discovery first of all of russian
starting 10 years ago
particularly i just love the 19th
century
novels like people tell you well you
shouldn't read that language because
it's not modern something i don't
believe that at all it's actually very
very similar
and and just the whole discovery of that
and then getting onto the ukrainian
thing and learning about then ukrainian
history and of course all the different
fighting that's going on yeah
not just fighting but all the different
disputes and stuff
it's been fascinating like i know
especially like ukraine like all of a
sudden hark of odessa you know
all these places exist and so through
the language let's say with russia
through the language you learn so much
about about the country the country
comes alive and by the way i really hope
things settle down in ukraine it's just
to me it's just well hopefully hopefully
they will someday uh but now it's still
you know it's still hot
uh yeah you know maybe maybe it's
definitely not for this video but maybe
we can uh disc if you are still
interested in that period and then
i mean we can we can discuss
my perspective what is going on in
ukraine because i'm i'm originally i'm
russian so i have no ukrainian blood in
me right
you